what the [__] is this NASCAR team what
dude are you into that is that yours I
love it man I love it I love I don't get
it well you know I always run around and
tell people my story is the ultimate
negative the positive you know so how
you flip NASCAR is a negative the
positive it started with bootlegging and
moonshining and if if you really know
the story of what NASCAR's been through
to become one of the biggest Sports if
not the biggest sport in the United
States of America yeah
that's what I fell in love with so you
love cars no I love the underdog
fighting Spirit of what it is to be a
part of a NASCAR team which is track
house the whole track house team they've
done phenomenal we've been in NASCAR now
for three years last year both drivers
made it to the playoffs and one of them
came number two Michael Jordan has a
team too yeah yeah do you party with him
at all no I don't I don't party with
Jordan but I've seen him at the races
last time it's funny because last time I
was with Jordan at the race it was in
we were in Homestead and he's got a an
amazing tequila and congratulations to
him and his his tequila cincotto is the
name of it so I go to take a shot of it
because that's what I got taught how to
do with tequila and he stopped me and
said nah you don't take a shot of that
you sip that really ship it no I said
all right Mike no problems matter with
him well let me tell you I didn't take
the shot I did sip it and I got [__]
up so
yeah
I guess he knows what he's talking about
one time for Michael Jordan and
everything that he's got going on God
bless
good